you need to keep her hydrated i'm trying
but we barely have any water left as it
is
tahiti you sure she'll never walk again
it'd be a miracle if she did
so
no matter where i go your kind get
uglier and
uglier
so
so
uh
[Music]
i don't understand we're getting closer
to the signal
the only way to be transmitting is if
the anomaly's effects were declining
but instead the anomaly here
is worse than anything we've seen could
it be we're approaching something like
the eye of the storm
it's possible but such an abrupt change
in climate from tropical to desert
only the anomaly could cause something
so dramatic
what if it's actually getting worse
that cave looks promising
i found a cave should be big enough to
bring the trucks in
on our way this storm is getting worse
by the minute
looks like we may be here a while
you need to drink you stupid [ __ ]
hey she's waking up
hey hey how do you feel
you've been out a few days
i i can't
i can't i can't feel my legs i'm sorry
bailey
why didn't you just kill me
tada my masterpiece
the broski has outdone himself again
what what did i do now
oh i thought my daughter wanted you to
live
for god knows what reason kill me
or get out of my face
jonah
is that a fire out there
seems we're not alone more in the others
i'll go check it out
you